here's a controversial thing when i do
eat cereal i don't eat it without milk
i'd eat it without milk
i want my cereal dry i think i think the
milk ruins it's better than
f people who say like [ __ ] monsters
who say like oh yeah he's watering
okay that that that that is a level even
i won't stoop too i'm pretty sure that's
like
in like jiva convention that you can't
do that like that's like that's like
[ __ ] up
like it goes against basic human rights
yeah i dude i knew a guy that's my
[ __ ] i knew a guy about uni no i saw
him [ __ ] do it too i knew a guy in my
uni who did you call the police
dead ass yeah i was about to i i think
i'm being assaulted right now
my eyes are being assaulted no it was
[ __ ] disgusting i never condoned like
spitting in someone's food but
yeah i think i think there's an
exception to people yeah he was eating
uh like uh like just
and it was like basic ass cornflakes as
well right and i'm like it's already a
human rights crime to just eat
cornflakes with nothing in it actually
let alone with water
any conflicts you know no nothing
depends on the cornflakes yeah but like
eating it with water is like
that's what you use like yeah it's like
here let me talk about that
who likes the cereal when it's the
soggiest right because that's all you're
doing you're just making your cereal
soggy
exactly like what are you are you that
desperate for hydration that you need to
go through your [ __ ] corn flakes like
what the [ __ ] yeah that's why when i
whenever i used to eat cereal in high
school i would eat that [ __ ]
did he make it through high school or
did he like just not make it i mean
he was in my uni so i guess he did oh
[ __ ] okay wow
are you that much of a baroque uni
student that you can't even afford milk
you just go to the tap and you're like
here we go again another day
i don't know what it is about uni and
like communal kitchens and
the ones the one thing that's that
always gets taken in the communal
kitchens is the milk
it's always the milk i don't know why
everything else
is just like you can take it and you
think they won't notice that's why
everyone does it like you can label your
cutlery you can label your food to be
like don't touch this don't touch this
you can label your milk but it never
works your milk will
inevitably disappear in like a day or
two yeah because it's like a lost
currency right it's like it's like water
but with calories
i remember i spotted with attitude
attitude
i had a i had a friend who's in my dorm
and i i liked him and then one time
yeah i did like him but now yeah you did
you know he was really high and then i i
came in like stoned yeah stone yeah he
was really stoned and then i
i walk in and i see him eating uh
cookies and cream ben and jerry's and
i'm like okay
i'm like where's my is that that's not
my cookies and cream
jerry's is it and he's like oh sorry
i'll uh i'll buy you one tomorrow
and i'm like i was gonna eat that
tonight i
planned a great evening watching anime i
was gonna eat that
i don't want your shitty tesco's one
pound
four kilograms of vanilla that looks
brighter than like
yellow on the like hexadecimal thing i
don't want that ice cream that tastes
like [ __ ] why would you
that pissed me off so much yeah like
vanilla ice cream that's like way too
yellow for its own good scares me
oh yeah that ain't like that's like a
fear i have i have a fear of heights and
way too yellow vanilla rice it doesn't
even taste like ice cream it tastes like
something i don't know what it is like
that's
like i don't want to eat so what's even
worse than that is when you get the soft
serve
and the soft serve isn't white and it's
yellow have you ever had that i know
because at that point where did you get
that from okay it's it's it's not like
the
it's it's always just in like the
[ __ ] ice cream vans that only come
out in the summer in england in japan
not
that's a british move